so crazy story about benjamin franklin
there was once a time where he had an
enemy a big enemy they're
going back and forth and eventually
figures out a way to
get closer to him he says you know what
maybe i'm going to ask him for help i'm
going to ask him to borrow
one of his books he borrows the book the
enemy lends him the book
he puts the book in his office never
reads the book a week later he gives it
back to the enemy he says thank you so
much for lending me the book
all of a sudden him and the enemy became
best of friends how does this happen
because he
had the guts to ask somebody for help so
today we're going to talk about 12
reasons why maybe you don't ask for help
seven ways to ask for help and seven
benefits if you actually
ask for help
okay so if this is a topic you're
excited about i want you to give me a
thumbs up as well as subscribe to the
channel stay tuned till the end i'm
gonna give you a pdf on today's topic so
let's get right into it number one
reason why we don't ask for help
is because it shows weakness you feel
like if if i ask this person for help
why would i ask for help i'm strong
i don't need your help i can do it on my
own why would i ask you a question like
this
because we're worried because we're
going to seem weak number two
perfectionist
perfectionists have a hard time asking
for help because they don't think
anybody can do the job as good as they
can so
they have a very hard time having people
around them that help them because like
let me just do myself you know what i'm
just gonna do this on my own
you guys can't figure this stuff out i'm
gonna do it on my own that's a
perfectionist right and if you have that
personality
you're gonna build a very small team
because no one around you is going to be
eventually learning how to do their job
because you keep doing
everyone's job yourself number three
you're afraid because if you ask
and you say hey john um i need your help
in this one area i needed a referral for
this person do you know of anybody yeah
i can't really help you in that area
the idea of the other person saying no
to you scares you so much because you're
so afraid of rejection
so what do you do you don't even ask for
help so fear of rejection is one of the
reasons why we don't ask for help number
four
shame what if the other person questions
your expertise like
wait a minute i i thought this person
knew what they were doing
you know they don't know what they're
doing why are they asking in your mind
you're thinking they're thinking that
so you're ashamed of saying i'm like i
don't want other people to think that i
don't know what i'm doing god forbid
people find that i don't know it all
then what do i do it's a little bit of a
mental game again we play
number five don't like owing favors and
return if you ask somebody for help
that person may six months later have to
ask you for help
and you don't want to be able to oh help
back to the person so you're like you
know what
i don't want to be in debt so because of
that i'm not going to ask you for all
because god forbid you ask me back
for help i have to say yes to you number
six is don't want to be seen as
needy sometimes people who ask for help
they're a little too needy
you need me am i needy i don't want to
be needy i don't need you i'm good we
don't want to be seen as needy number
seven don't feel you've earned the right
to ask for help i haven't yet earned the
right to ask for help by the way this is
actually a
very noble reason when somebody doesn't
feel they've earned the right to ask for
help and sometimes you may be right
where you haven't done enough you
haven't watered the relationship enough
to ask for help but many times nine out
of 10 times
you've earned the right to ask for help
you can ask for because we're going to
say to you is what no
number eight feeling judged the same
thing as goes with shame i don't want to
be judged for asking for help number
nine you don't want
to burden someone else if i ask you for
help that means you got to take time out
of your schedule to come and help me out
i don't know if i want to burden you
with that kind of help so it's kind of
like i don't want to i don't want to
make other people's life
i'll do everything for you what do you
need help from me but i don't want to
put that burden on you and that mindset
limits
how big of a thing you can build
yourself business-wise number 10
bandwidth of contact
is limited you just may not have the
right bandwidth you may not have that
many deep relationships yesterday on one
of the
elite masterminds i do on a monthly
basis with different entrepreneurs
around the world
one of the guys was asking about
relationships and how does he get the
right kind of employees i said
the best employees investors sales
people contacts technology engineers
the best i've ever gotten is by asking
for referrals
from people from with very high level of
credibility because
the level of credibility of a person
that gives me a referral is typically
the level of quality
of the referral i get so maybe your
current
bandwidth of context you have is not
that strong and you need to increase it
and you may be right in that so we got
to improve
the context you have number 11 don't
know how to ask for help which we'll
talk about
and number 12 some prefer to help rather
than
to be helped you like others you like to
go out and help others because it makes
you feel so needed and special
but you don't want others to feel the
same way as you do you just want to help
others god forbid your
other people you know you ask for other
people for help it's not going to happen
for you so again it's a mental block
some have to deal with next seven ways
to ask for help number one
be clear on what you need help with the
general
asking for general help people don't
know how to help he's got to be specific
here's what i'm looking for do you know
anybody who
dot dot dot rather than hey i'm thinking
about doing this
what do you think about this can you
help me with this it's general i'm
thinking about doing this here's the
five things i need pom pom pom pom do
you know anybody who can help me get
this done yes no maybe but at least
you're going to be clear
on what you're asking for number two
16 years ago i'm asking the company i'm
working for for a lot of things can we
do this can we do this can we do that
can we do this
one of the ceos who's running this
multi-billion dollar company pulls me
inside says can i ask you uh uh
can i give you some counsel i said
absolutely what's that he said
you ask for so many things that you want
to see this company go to the next one i
got to tell you i love all your ideas
you got a lot of great ideas
he said but here's the problem you're
dealing with corporate and sometimes
when you're dealing with corporate
they don't like it when you give them
seven things that they need to work on
and improve on
he says what's the one thing if in the
next six months you can only ask for one
thing
to help and improve them what would it
be and i said probably this he says then
only ask for that and nothing else
but ask for that 20 times rather than
asking for
20 things right so focus one thing to
help
ask for help rather than many different
things number three
give in advance if any chance you get to
help others say is there any way i can
help you is there any way i can help you
is there anyone can help you is there
anything you need help with is there any
contacts
is there anything make that part of your
repertoire constantly be asking people
how you
can help them because in return when you
ask for help they're going to be
thinking and saying well this guy's
helped me out as well
no problem let me go out of my way to
help you number four give them an out
to say no so listen i don't want you to
be fully committed to having to say yes
or no but i need help with something
here if you can't great if you can't no
problem
this gives me the ability to not feel
pressure to have to say yes or no and
believe it or not the fact
that i'm not pressured to say yes or no
i want to do more
for you if that makes any sense so
listen you may or may not be able to
help me out in this area but if you can
i will greatly appreciate it here's what
it is i need that
do you know anybody actually know what i
do let me think about i'll get back to
you and they'll get back to you number
five
thank them regardless of yes or no so
they say
no i can't help you don't give them an
attitude
don't block them on twitter don't block
them on text
just say hey all good totally understand
appreciate you even offering no
i figured you were going to be busy but
i wanted to ask you anyways thank you
next one when
asking for help it helps more if you're
doing it in person rather than a text
or a you know email or you know a dm
it's 34. research has shown 34 times
more effective
if you ask for help face to face instead
of text email
or dm last but not least over here if
somebody helps you
give credit tell the world about it i am
so glad i met
oscar through bobby bobby thank you
because now bobby wants to introduce you
to
more people i am so glad that i was able
to raise money
from such and such investment from
because jack introduced me to them or
else i would have never met them
thank you jack the more you give credit
to people that have helped you
the more people want to continue to help
you my content that i come up with
is based on a lot of books a lot of
relationships a lot of people i've
worked with a lot of mentors a lot of
advisors a lot of this one a lot of
people i've worked with
and anybody if there's any feeling
people don't like
is if somebody helped you get to where
you are today
you got to give them public credit or
else it's going to be like why am i
going to help you more often in your
life so that's that part if somebody
helps you tell the world about it next
one is
seven benefits for asking for help
number one you will find solutions to
your problems faster
you do by yourself it's gonna take
longer so imagine how much is it worth
you to fix this problem six days versus
six months what is it worth you speed
number two
you got others to be vested into your
problem being solved
it's like hey did we figure that part
out we did we figured yeah we finally
were able to raise that money we were
finally able to hire that one person
we were finally able to get that office
awesome and i'm so happy for you i'm
glad i was able to help
so people are vested in helping your
mission become a reality number three
creates a stronger bond remember that
whole ben franklin with his enemy the
book can you help me thank you for your
help
creates a stronger bond number four a
sign of a big thinker the bigger you
think the more help you need you're
comfortable asking other people for help
number five
is humility is healthy asking for help
means you don't know it all
people like humble people it's more
attractive it's also better for your
mental health
because you don't feel like you're all
by yourself because the last point is
what
loners carry heavy weight
when you ask for help you are rarely
alone because others want to come for
the ride
with you so having said that if you got
value from today's episode smash thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel and text
award ask for help to
three four zero one one three two three
one zero three four zero
one one three two you will get the pdf
what we talked about in today's episode
and outside of that if you enjoyed this
video
i got another video for you to watch
it's titled ten questions
everyone must ask take care everybody
[Music]
bye